[Applause]
well dolbajan made that difficult for
him for close range
matthew's right on buddy behind uh
didn't stay with him though
speaking of buddy behind buddy buckets
comes right out with his first shot
knocks it down
[Applause]
there you go first basket since 53
seconds into the game billy burke
hopefully proud
you've got to kick it here you got
behind wide open there he is for a
second of the half
wow that's the problem this is changed
two-point ball game 12 to go and no
inside game right now
bayheim answers back with a three right
you deserve some plaudits
mcneil's made a couple of those from
even beyond that watch out
yeah talking about way out there
wow does that silence it a little bit a
contributor
a little nylon from deep oh you don't
contest that
he's gonna make you pay and why not well
we still got nine minutes to go yeah
yeah
okay oh that'll get him stirred
second turnover of the half beijing head
fake gets to the hole smart
gets it to go don't go under
well they can elevate now he knows
two-point jumper so smart
those a major issue
once again the ability to elevate
seriously
yeah are you as you would say serious